pour évoquer la réforme des retraites
nicolas vidal éditorialistes bonsoir
nicolas vidal merci d'être avec nous sur
arte france ce soir la réforme des
retraites la priorité pour bruno le
maire
hier dans le jdd le ministre de
l'économie et un texte qui ne peut pas
être repris en l'état d'après emmanuel
macron dans le lot la semaine dernière
il sera d'ailleurs à valence demain pour
son tour de france des territoires qui
croire vous savez il faut suivre
toujours emmanuel macron dans ces
décisions là bruno le maire assé
seulement lui l'adjudant-chef de
d'emmanuel macro mais moi j'aime bien
emmanuel macron c'était extrêmement
intéressant vous savez pas ce que je
veux je lis finhan les textes européens
emmanuel macron dans le sujet que vous
venez de passer c'est formidable parce
que manuellement convoquant tous les
termes de la commission européenne de
bruxelles notamment sur la solidité des
dépenses publiques et c'est sa réforme
cardinal emmanuel macron depuis le début
du quinquennat
donc ça a été effectivement vous l'aviez
d'un reportage arrêté par la crise qu
vide mais emmanuel macron il a plus
beaucoup de temps aujourd'hui et
personnellement je l' ai dit plusieurs
fois sur l'antenne d'arte france
je pensais qu'ils n'auraient pas le
temps de la passer concrètement et bien
sûr il n'aura pas le temps de la passer
dans l'état dans l'état de fin 2019 bien
entendu mais on va voir pourquoi et
qu'est ce qu'il devrait faire passer
manuellement de macron finalement à
l'été un moule à midi d'un sujet dès
juillet ils vont aussi mettre dessus il
y aura une conférence sociale or là on
va on va rigoler sur la conférence
sociale parce que manuel mâcon cette
réforme là c'est absolument sa réforme
cardinal et c'est pas que la réforme du
manuel macron l'arrêter c'est la réforme
voulue par la commission européenne je
file à tuer pour cette première question
daniel marchand a dit on l'entendait la
dent dans le sujet
la mère des réformes c'est le travail et
la reprise d'activité
donc ça veut dire quoi se dire que la
réforme des retraites elle va être
repoussée elle va différente elle va
ressembler à quoi au final
alors vous l'avez dit effectivement
aujourd'hui si la reprise du travail on
est d'accord c'est le kobe tu vas y voir
une crise économique avait déjà la crise
économique donc emmanuel macron il fait
passer sa juste avant mais là il va
reprendre la réforme des retraites et
qu'est ce qui va faire passer manuel
macro vous comprenez bien que la réforme
a point elle était impossible est
impossible on doit faire passer
aujourd'hui nous sommes en juin 2021
c'est en et 2022 il sera totalement
impossible de tout reformater de
remettre en place un nouveau système de
répartition c'est ça donc il va essayer
finalement de faire une retraite
on vous l'avait dit le on va repousser
l'âge de départ légal c'est ça qui va
faire donc maintenant il va mettre le
pied dans la porte et manuellement
prompt pour donner quoi
pour donner des gages à bruxelles parce
que un maniaque makwaia accélère parce
que vous le savez il ya eu un plan de
relance qui a été négociée a été
acceptée par emmanuel macron à bruxelles
et effectivement la réforme des
retraites apparaît notamment dans ce
plan de relance la france comme d'autres
pays doit absolument faire passer la
réforme des retraites et c'est pas le
sujet de ce soir
il ya aussi la réforme d'assurance
chômage au 1er juillet donc voyez c'est
le package finalement de ce plan de
relance dont emmanuel macron il fait
quoi
il axe est relatif et il faudra passer
leur retraite pas celle d'avant
d'ailleurs a été trop compliqué il l'a
dit lui même né commencera à mettre le
pied dans la porte
emmanuel macron de cette réforme
absolument néo libérale mais quand il
dit que le texte ne peut pas être repris
en l'état ça veut dire quoi concrètement
c'est à dire qu'on va vers une réforme
bien ce que c'est simplement pour
déminer la rentrée sociale qui s'annonce
musclée dans les rues alors oui mais la
réforme est très gros semblait être
simplifiées pour passer on va par où il
va pas pouvoir demander à bercy de
refaire tout le système
s'il avait été en janvier il avait
pratiquement depuis deux ans pour le
faire ils font même un peu plus deux ans
et demi aujourd'hui il est obligé
d'accélérer et je vais toujours dit ce
que l'on tienne la cri du coc vida
emmanuel macron la forte demande
fortement embêter fortement endetté
d'emmener il s'en sert aussi pour faire
accélérer la réforme avec nous n'allons
pas laisser abattre nos enfants tout le
tout ce qu'on a entendu sur ce débat la
réforme des retraites qui était très
compliqué d'ailleurs très très compliqué
et aujourd'hui je le répète un il c'est
le pied dans la porte il va devant la
faire passer absolument gay va devoir
devoir donner
gage de crédibilité je vais dire maman
gros mot je veux dire en gage de
soumission aux diktats bruxellois qui a
été négociée en notre nom je le rappelle
toujours en juillet 2000 en juillet en
juillet dernier on juil 2020 et pourtant
les retraites en 2019 ses 14 6% des
dépenses que gliese public ça un poste
qui ne cesse d'augmenter
donc faut quand même la réformer un
système qu'il n'est pas toujours
équitable notamment avec les régimes
spéciaux comment est ce qu'on fait pour
trouver un consensus
alors le consensus en fait il est je
pense qu'il est plutôt globale vous
pouvez pas un moment donné détruire un
pays
délocaliser d'esprit les 10 et faire
énormément de chômeurs il ya beaucoup de
licenciements
regardez bridgestone notamment et vous
pouvez pas demander finalement de mettre
des actifs sur le carreau avec avec ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui en france est
avec ses réformes néolibérales avec la
flexibilisation rappelez-vous du marché
du travail du droit du travail même est
demandée aussi après d'aller travailler
plus longtemps tout ça va de mon parce
qu'en fait les libéraux que je lis je
lis notamment ses interviews ou ses
articles sur les libéraux ils ne parlent
jamais d'un truc très simple et delà des
ravages de la mondialisation
vous ne pouvez pas faire une réforme des
retraites telle qu'elle est une réforme
de l'assurance chômage
aujourd'hui en france deux chiffres 10
ans les 9 millions de pauvres 9 millions
de pauvres c'est absolument incroyable
et vous avez près de 6 millions de
chômeurs dans ce premier premier
semestre trimestre par donc 2021 vous
voyez bien que moment donné on peut pas
faire tout et n'importe quoi il ya un
pays qui est sous la crise économie de
suite à la crise sanitaire les ravages
de la mondialisation je cite bridgestone
y en a plein d'autres 8 163 emplois
qu'elles seront qui ont été détruits il
ya quelques semaines et vous pouvez pas
demander aux gens fictivement d'aller
travailler beaucoup plus longtemps
j'en cite une réforme systémique c'est
une réforme même pas 6/2 et une réforme
idéologique
en réalité je le répète et je suis très
déçu qu'on ne fera jamais le lien entre
l'union européenne la politique
néolibérale et cette réforme des
retraites qui est idéologique deux
derniers chiffres pour répondre à votre
question la tulle par exemple vous avez
évasion fiscale 80 milliards d'euros et
vous avez aussi la fraude sociale en
quête du très bon magistrat charles le
prat choc on est donc ça aussi c'est les
chiffres si on veut récupérer les 24
milliards de dettes sur l'année 2020 on
peut aller aussi mettre des politiques
de contrôle sur l'évasion fiscale et sur
la fraude sociale
des sujets explosifs qui sont passés
sous le boisseau totalement pour la
réforme des retraites
merci nicolas vidal d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
éditorialistes